but after being dark for months and
months live entertainment is finally
returning to the las vegas strip yeah
such a good news for our economy here in
the valley bianca holmen live on the
stage over at the luxor with the gals
from fantasy bianca
we've got the music ready we've got
everything ready so we're also
excited to see your strip headlining
begin now
exactly i'm ready to audition for the
girls here and you know maybe be a
featured dancer
like our featured dancer here mariah
rivera who's also
the associate producer so tell us i know
you all have been on for about a week
now you all started back last friday
what is that experience like for the 100
guests that are allowed in well
hopefully it's very exciting yeah we're
we're trying to give them everything we
have we have only 100 people in the
audience as you said so we're selling
tickets in twos and fours
socially distancing so we're in a huge
new theater so it feels a little
different than we're used to
but um the audience is definitely still
going to get the same show that they're
they're used to
exciting and also for you all i know you
have to you all have adjusted the show
and you all have to wear masks so are
you wearing the glittery ones you have a
clear one what how are you all conveying
that emotion
we we tried the glitter ones but we're
still we're so smiley and just such
entertainers with our you know all of
our assets
so we we found very cool uh clear masks
where you can still see us
our smiles you know for you know little
playful things because it just took so
much of our performance away without our
our full face yes all right well i hear
they got some music for me
i've been trying to audition for the
chorus line out here let me see if i can
hear the music
let's see if they got it for me all
right ready
all right we're going to count in five
six
five six seven eight two
six seven eight that was it
you got a spot for me on the chorus line
thank you
thank you thank you send it back to you
guys in the studio again they've got
tickets they got two shows on sunday
so definitely let's come out and support
our local entertainment here
on the las vegas strip back to you guys
in the studio bianca
you nailed it that count was even good
music
i nailed it that damn count it's all
about the music
bianca now you just gotta get the
producers there you guys can work at a
deal some sort of an arrangement and uh
and make things
happen at the end him comes back bianca
of course bianca live
yes i was expecting a longer performance
that was uh kind of short
sherry wants an encore sherry wants it
encore
you did great bianca bianca's like you
can't afford me
thank you sherry all right i'll do a
special show just for you
all right well it was so good i wanted
to see it twice